good evening thanks for joining us here
at 11 i'm denise valdez
a long-awaited announcement for families
tonight contact sports
are allowed to resume statewide and that
includes both practice and competition
but comes with some strings attached 8
news now reporter madison kimbrough is
live tonight with what leagues need to
know
madison yes coaches parents and most of
all athletes are rejoicing tonight
as recreational sports such as
basketball football group dance and even
water polo will resume once again
we're all ecstatic we've been waiting
for this consideration
major news for nevadans who play sports
governor sysolak announcing today that
full close contact sports can now resume
this is after
months and months of restrictions put in
place to keep people safe from covet 19.
the governor's medical advisory team
supported the move with its latest
recommendations
and now athletes of all ages can play
recreationally again
but for student athletes this is a much
needed step the kids were hurting
the kids wanted that outlet it's been
very frustrating you know you can't
really play
defense as well it's harder for you to
steal the ball and just play and
practice in general
organized leagues clubs and associations
must implement a sports
safety plan which includes baseline
requirements
protocols and restrictions before anyone
can play the rules say face coverings
must be worn by coaches and players
among other things starting tomorrow we
have to put together our plan which is
already ready
because we've been advocating for months
additionally certain testing and
mitigation measures will also need to be
put in place before a game or practice
can take place
we have demonstrated that we can do it
safely we can be responsible
we can make sure that we utilize all the
precautions necessary
and still have a great time
and some good news in henderson tonight
the city says they're going to start
putting up their basketball
hoops tomorrow with the hope of putting
them all up by next week
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now